what's up everybody I'm Jacob Scott
Thomas Bertrand I'm Charlotte Maria and
we are here with BuzzFeed to take the
BFF friendship challenge quiz test quiz
challenge test nice
full birthday I know this one dude I'm
nervous June 9th 2001. yeah and yours is
March 6 2000. yeah
all right okay this one's easy parents
names
I don't know if I should say what's my
mother's maiden name dog
[Music]
um
Christina yeah first time you met uh at
lunch cafeteria yeah in the cafeteria my
mom could not print out your name right
she kept calling him cholo and I was
like Mom please stop it's our first time
eating him I don't know your first
acting job
um was it a Sears commercial yeah yeah
it was first thing yeah the first thing
I did is serious commercial and the
first thing Jacob did locked in the
vault was an Oscar Meyer commercial yeah
yeah weenies the last show they binge
watched the last thing I remember you
talking about was House of dragon uh the
last show you binged I don't even know
is it was it an anime it was an anime I
don't know I'm definitely not gonna know
that it was mob Psycho Mob psycho 100.
okay season three is coming out soon so
I want to rewatch it their favorite
Cobra Kai scene do you film together
wait wait so so this one I'm supposed to
guess what yours yeah is it's a fight
yeah and it's the fight that we have
together yeah
uh I would say ditto yeah their biggest
pet peeve what's my biggest pet peeve
Jacob I'm curious oh picky eaters he
hates people okay if you're a picky
eater he knows you no I feel like people
who don't have a competitive Spirit
you're like give up in games and you get
mad
I'm like that's a that's a pet peeve of
Jacob's favorite Batman film yours is
probably the Dark Knight it is The Dark
Knight yeah I want to say the Robert
padson one but not because it's Robert
Pattinson because Zoe Kravitz is in it
uh no no no mine is also the Dark Knight
oh is it really but I do like the new
one I did pretty like habits
biggest celebrity crush probably I feel
like it's ebbed and flowed when I met
him it was Rihanna
and then maybe
through his early years in college it
was
Zoe Kravitz my two puppies they're
celebrities that have Instagram accounts
good answer your celebrity crush Jacob
the lady from the remake of Just Dance
no not Just Dance Not Just Dance
Footloose there you go Julianne Hough
Nathan Fielder I [ __ ] love Nathan
he's hilarious your favorite swear word
Jacob never used to swear and now this
past year he started swear more and it's
unsettling it's like when a child says
like what are you saying I know that's
that's your favorite one yeah it's the
one I say the most probably I feel like
you say all the time
not true to everyone in the room it's
either that or cunnilingus I don't know
if that's a swear word I do use that one
often yeah I use the abbreviated version
though that was some crazy seal that's
just some crazy silly the hardest stunts
you've ever filmed for Cobra Kai Jacob I
feel like wire stuff is always kind of
hard yeah the K-pop was like the only
thing I did oh I did that um you did
like the all Valley I did like this uh
we have no really practice with the
wires yeah we don't train that a lot so
it's it's they're like just get it just
do it right on the day their favorite
superhero or villain uh Nova
[Laughter]
your favorite superhero uh is Moon
Knight I do like a moon night Jacob
really likes Moon Knights and
um also we're pitching you for the Kid
Flash for when they want to oh more
Wally West baby yeah for when they
decide to put Blue Beetle in the Teen
Titans I think that's just
him just because I'm I'm just as fast
their favorite lone Lobos podcast
episode what's your favorite one oh with
our live episode with Blake and live
episode of Live episode probably one of
my favorites yeah we did a we did a live
stream where we force-fed our friends
grapes until they how many grapes he
could fit so
um I really like the episode where we
talked about Young Thug Young Thug is
colorblind that's oh is that the it okay
yeah their preferred pizza topping when
you did eat pizza I feel like you like
meat lovers oh no nasty no way I think
he's just like pepperoni because you're
Bland but
it's actually if I was mine would be
mushroom oh that's a good one yeah I
like the supreme pizzas the one with the
is that not the same thing no it's like
it's like onions bell peppers mushrooms
and memes yeah but meat lovers is just
meat that's like sausage pepperoni
salami prosciutto Anchovies and no their
least favorite food you don't like boba
I don't like Boba I don't like Boba I
Hate Everything dude I know I'm like you
love everything no there's one thing
that I that you know that I don't like
we're not BFFs anymore
oh
[Music]
[ __ ] you gotta think of the Capers
Capers that's underrepresented yeah
that's right but you do for a good
reason they're trash the go-to karaoke
song we've never been to karaoke before
I don't know you're you're like a white
guy though you're like sweet girl
Jordan's sons come on every time I play
Muppets and there's like their go-to
karaoke song
[Music]
this is my actual one
my song was only girl in the world by
Rihanna and Jacobs was that Bohemian
Rhapsody Bohemian Rhapsody is like end
of the night I feel like that's a good
test like if someone doesn't know all
the words of Bohemian Rhapsody it's like
I trust you
I yeah you can you don't know the words
no are you serious no yes you do no
there's no way you don't no I don't what
no what about um no none of the queen
song Piano Man
you don't know all the words of piano
I got 13 out of 17. I got 14 out of 17.
you know you know absolutely everything
there is to know about your best friend
all right thanks so much guys you can
check us out on bat wheels on HBO Max or
Cartoon Network you can also check us
out on COBRA Kai season 5 on Netflix
thanks BuzzFeed
[Music]